[Music]
you taught your Dad
recently
[Music]
why give us a
call
hey so where did you appear
from
[Music]
Oklahoma I've never been Anywhere But
Here what were you doing with that big
girl get a lot of crazy ass foreigners
mostly how's it going
guys this here is Jackie hi she needs a
job say she'll do anything yeah you like
guns not really what the [__] you doing
here
then a bit more powerful than a punch
huh [__] yeah call me when it's
done what is this
place huh you don't
understand get back in the
carun they found a
body Le I keep gra your hands
B don't regret
this
will just mean to fight
back I'm going to tell them everything
you ever did FBI open up are you
threatening
me
yep that was really stupid
honey
no never for
[Music]
okay